so welcome to the set of
some videos giving a introduction to
probabilistic systems and probabilistic
model checking
so i'll start by just saying why do we
need to
have slot probability so some
systems are inherently probabilistic so
to give some
examples we need some randomization in
distributed
coordination algorithms so this is used
as a
it's like symmetry breaker for example
in site leader
selection it's like protocols and there
are some real world
slight examples that um of some
protocols that include
slight randomization and these in and
these
include their ieee 802.3
just like wireless lan so here if two
slot devices send at the same time and
there's a
a collision then they use a it's like
randomized select backus
scheme so this is the amount of time
they wait except before trying to send
again randomization is also used in the
ieee
firewire or it's like root contention
protocol and we'll see that soon it's
also used in
it's like the brute the bluetooth select
protocol
and here there's a random choice of
waiting time
it's also used in the ipv4 um
zero comp it's like a dynamic
configuration so here um when it chooses
a
um ip address then it
makes a slight random choice over the
set of possible
addresses so there's a high chance that
it doesn't choose
an address that is already in slight use
it's also used in it's anonymity and
contract signing select protocols
so it's also it's a probability it's
used to model
uncertainty and it's like performance
and then we can quantify it's like the
rate of
failures or the quality of such service
of a
slight system and some examples of this
are inside computers
networks and in embedded systems and
also in power management
slap policies and probability is also
used in
um nanoscale
slight circuitry so here since the
circuits
are so small so you can't it's like
guarantee they are
it's like reliable but you can solve
this
through um fault tolerance by having
um extra circuits doing the same thing
okay and it's also used as um
for the quantitative analysis of
software
and of systems so for example we can use
it to
um uh find out
the minimum battery um
capacity that we need to use for a given
slight scenario okay and there's many
other applications
which require select probability
such as biological systems
so in the standard model checking
approach you have your site system that
is usually
modeled as a finite um state sub model
such as a
select crypt key [ __ ] structure or a
labeled
transition system you have your system
select requirements these are usually
modeled in some um temporal
logic for example ltl and then these are
inputted to some model checker for
example
spin and then start the model checker so
automatically so that verifies if the
given
specification holds for the given
finance state
slap model so it can return either yes
so the specification is satisfied or no
such specification isn't and in the case
that it isn't it it can also give a
slight it's like counter example
or an error trace showing why the given
specification
doesn't hold okay this could be extended
to
probabilistic it's like model checking
so here it's like the system so again
is a sort of finite state transition
system
but here there is also slight
probabilities that label
the transitions and one such example is
a
select markov chain and then and in this
set of set videos we will consider both
select discrete time except markov
chains
and markup select decision just like
processors
for the system select requirements so
again
it's given as a temple it's like logic
but obviously here it's a
um it's a probabilistic it's not
temporal
logic and in this set of videos i will
concentrate just on
the simple um properties of
probabilistic so reachability and
expected
self-reachability so we give it's like
the system
and just like the specification
to some probabilistic model checker for
example
it's not prism and then so again you can
get
whether the result is true or false you
can also get
it's like quantitative results for
example you can ask
what is the maximum or minimum
it's like probability that some set of
states is reached for example
what's the maximum it's like probability
that an
error occurs or what's the minimum it's
like probability that the system
selects like two minutes and again you
you can also get a slight counter
example but here it's
it's harder as now it's not a simple
it's not error trace
but it's a um set of it's like paths
showing that um the property is not
satisfied with a certain
select probability okay so just to give
you one
concrete example um let's have a look at
the firewire
protocol okay so here this is a high
slot performance
serial bus full it's like
select networking it was um originally
introduced by apple so the idea here
that it's hot are pluggable so you can
add and
just like remove select devices at any
time and it will
reconfigure and there's no
requirements to have a single sort of
it's like central
or device for example a a pc
so what happens is when a new
our device is added um then a new
site root for their um for the network
is
are created so this is all a
it's like the route we can consider as a
it's like leader
so there's a leader selection algorithm
so this is a symmetric distributed
protocol and it uses electronic
coin tossing as we will see so
when a new device um joins
then the nodes send it's like messages
to be my
our parent and there's a root contention
when two nodes send be my parent
set messages to each other and when this
stuff happens then these two site nodes
will
toss coins and this will tell them
whether to wait a um fast or a slow
slight delay it's like before re it's
like trying
so here's an example our configuration
so what happens is that node sends
node send be my parent our requests when
all but one of its
neighbors um are
it's like children okay so here
at the start we've got these outer nodes
um
these only have one um
it's like connection and therefore they
will start by sending be my parent
our requests so we can have these nodes
start to send
our requests um
and this continues and then
finally we end up with a a situation
where there's only one um node
that um that hasn't sent
anything and this therefore so it
becomes the root of the
our network okay so what can go wrong is
that
as this as the requests are
sent then we have two notes each sending
be my parent and we
reach a root contention so what happens
here
is that they both flip a it's like they
both flip coins
so for example if they both flipped head
then they would wait for the same time
so they would wait for four so at the
same time and then they would send
again and obviously would still be in a
root or contention
but eventually one will flip ahead and
one will flip
a tail and therefore they will wait a
different time
so let's say the tail means wait a short
a short time while head means wait a
second long time
then the one that flip tail will send
the select request to select the other
and then we will have a route of this
um our network
so we've done some analysis of this
using it's like the probabilistic select
model chapter
select prism so here in
select the model we took all the timing
our delays from
it's like the standard and in this
model we have concurrency due to
certain messages being sent by the
different nodes
um so alongside the wires of the site
network
we also have a under our specification
so we get
non-determinism as this is the
specification only says that the delays
should be between
certain upper and lower up bands and
in so the models that we've it's like
considered
we've gone up to approximately 170
it's like million states and the
analysis
that we've formed will so we first
showed that
so the protocol is it's like correct so
that means that
it's like the root contention is always
like resolved with
probability one and then we've also
it's like investigated the time that it
takes
to find a it's like leader or to
solve the route it's like
um contention
and we've also looked at the effect of a
biased point so first using a it's like
standard coin so here there's a 50 50
chance that it waits a short or a long
time and here we've so plotted the um
minimum it's like probability of
electing a
leader by a given time band
both when there's a short wire between
the two nodes and a long wire
between the two nodes and so obviously
if
the wire is set longer it takes um
it will take just longer for the
messages to be sent
and uh sorry it will take longer for the
messages to
arrive and therefore the probability
will be smaller for a given time time
band
okay and what we've also done is look to
see what happens
as we have a biased coin so here so the
probability of it's like choosing fast
or
to wait a short time so it varies and
then
obviously so the probability that you
wait a slow or a
longer time is one minus this slope
probability
so this shows so um the minimum
probability of start electing a leader
by time t
and we've also looked at the maximum
it's like expected time to
elect a leader using a biased coin
and here we actually see that the
maximum expected time goes down when we
use a
slightly biased coin select towards
it's like waiting um um
a shorter time now why is this well
there's a a compromise here
and that if we have a it's like bias
coin um
then there's a slight greater chance
that they will
need to flip again but if it's not
biased
towards fast then when they do um flip
the same thing
then they wait a shorter time except
before
flipping again so there's a a compromise
between the time
when they flip the same and the chance
that they flip
select different so just to
give you some different
models that are used in probabilistic
slip model checking so there's a number
of
it's like discrete time so models which
are
set variants or extensions of
select markov chains so there's discrete
time
markov chains that we'll see in part one
there's markov
select decision set processes which
we'll see in part two of these
videos that's both turn-based and
concurrent stochastic games and there's
also partially
observable so markup decision except
processes and games and i'll say a
little bit more
about these on on the next slide
and there's also both it's like
continuous and real-time
it's like models so there's continuous
time
so markov chain secure the time that it
takes for
a our transition to
occur is exponentially or distributed
and we've got probabilistic time
automata
so here we have real time select clocks
and these have been
extended to both game-based slot
variants and adding
partial observability and there's also
the extension of
probabilistic automata to stochastic
hybrid automata so just to say
so something on the game based
models so here this allows um the
modeling of both
collaborative and competitive behavior
so between
some agents and these agents might have
either
differing or it's like opposing set
goals so for example
this comes up in security
where we have it's like the systems
such choices um are
the opposite of an attacker who is
trying to break
into the system and also in it's like
controller
it's like select synthesis where we have
the controllers
such choices versus those of the
environment
okay and just to say something on parcel
observability
so here um
actions are slip resolved
based only on sort of part of or
observations or part of the system
state so this is used for example a a
robot can only make it
our decisions based on its sensors
and not on the whole system state
or for example a our scheduler can't
probe the state of a
our component when it's making its
slight choices
so for our specifications it
informally we can have things like
what's the probability of
a a delivery it's like within a time
it's a deadline or what's the expected
time until a
slight message is are delivered or
what's that expected
power of consumption formally these are
specifications
can be defined in probabilistic
temporal logics and these include pctl
ltl csl and rp a
tl and there's a number of other logics
and for these for this so
videos i'll just focus on slightly
simple
select properties of probabilistic and
expected it's like reachability
and these are sort of like the
fundamental
properties of probabilistic
model checking now
what does probabilistic model tracking
involve well
it involves first the it's like
construction of
the model that's going to be slight
analysis
and this is from a usually from a a
description in a high level it's like
modeling such language
and then there's so the model checking
algorithms
themselves now these use
graph theoretic algorithms so these
are used for reachability for finding
strongly it's like connected
select components and also for um
qualitative
set properties so these are things which
hold with probability zero
or probability one or equally
probability greater than zero or
probability
less than one and then we also obviously
need
numeric our computation and this is
often in the form of
linear equation systems or linear
optimization
slope problems as we'll see in parts one
and two
and to solve these you can either use
iterative select methods or direct
select methods
there's also um other
approaches you need uniform
isolation and also shortest path slope
problems
we also need automata for
it's like regular our languages and ltl
select
slap properties and there's also
sampling based or statistical sort of
model checking for
approximate analysis so here you
uh generate a number of our simulations
and then you can test some for example
you can then test some
hypothesis and then you can sort of say
with some a probability
we believe this is the correct
answer so just to give
so finally some sort extensions so so
the focus
is either on verification but you can
also
consider our control so in
verification it's like you're verifying
that a system is
correct for any environment adversary or
a controller and the counter example
yields a floor or an attack for
the system on the other hand
uh in it's like it's like synthesis you
can
um build a correct by construction it's
like
controller from some formal for some
formal
a specification so here you go
a witness or a such a strategy or
a controller and it's often the case
that it's more important not to actually
verify but actually give a um
a controller and this is for example
applications are in
dynamic power management
in autonomous
vehicle select navigation in
task or select network select scheduling
and
select security it's also
going on to considering multiple
objectives so here you don't just
select verify that one a property holds
but you have
but you look at um
trade-offs select between conflicting
objectives or are specifications for
example there's a
there's a trade-off
between the cost and the quality of our
service
so obviously if you pay more you can get
a better quality
of service but you would like to
minimize the
slight cost given a given that you meet
a
certain quality of a service
so here you can actually have a mix of
select optimization and it's like
guarantees
so you can ask what is the strategy that
maximizes the probability of some
message
transmission while it's like
guaranteeing
that the expected battery life
is at least some given
value and you can also look into the
operito curve
as you improve one objective
so as you go up and um you improve one
sorry so as you go this
our direction for objective one so you
get a better
result for objective one then the
um bound on objective two
goes down so if you um
decrease the cost then that's going to
also cause a
slight decrease in the quality of our
service
so finally uh one extension is
to select parameter synthesis
so so what
many people have tried to do is to
synthesize
models that that are guaranteed to
satisfy some um a property now this is
very
a difficult step particularly in the
quantitative setting
however what we can do is
that we can synthesize it's like
controllers and
parameters okay so in some parameter
just like synthesis
for a given parametric select model
and a select property then we can look
for
the optimal select parameters
with respect to some objective
function so um such that
um so the property is
satisfied and we can look at so
quantitative
parameter it's like synthesis so here
set the parameters could be
timing our delays or it's like rates and
the
objectives could be to optimize it's
like the probability or the
expected of reward
so so finally just to say so
something on probabilistic except model
checking in practice
so one such probabilistic model checker
that i'm
so involved in is it's prism
which has been developed at birmingham
and
so oxford since um 19
it's like 99. it's free
open source can be used under all
operating
systems it it can handle most of
the models that i've discussed and
if you go to the prism website
then you can download the tool you can
find a large online
example it's a repository that has over
50 different
case studies there's online
documentation
this support um help
um there's a help
forum for example and there's also a um
all the related
publications talks and tutorials and
links can be found there for those that
are
interested so just to
acknowledge that the material that i'm
going to present
in the next two parts is based on
existing lecture courses that were
so prepared by dave parker
and and myself and also some of the
material is from both is from a buck
bite
it's a crystal bear and you speak to
cartoon okay so just to finally say what
is
in it's like in
the remaining video so in part one i'll
go over
sites like discrete time markov chains
so i'll introduce paths and
set probabilities probabilistic it's
like reachability
then i'll introduce some reward such
structures and go on to
expected self-reachability in part two
i'll
extend select discrete time select
markov chains and i'll consider markups
it's like decision type processors i'll
introduce paths
strategies and probabilities for these
um
select models and then i'll go on to
probabilistic site reachability for
mdps and i will consider these three
different ways
um for um i'll first
consider it's like it's like qualitative
probabilistic select reachability then
i'll introduce
slightly optimal optimality so equations
and how to compute
so reachability except probabilities so
each of these parts
um are basic
and is select material
that is suitable for new newcomers
so entering the field and then in the
live
a lecture i'll go on to an advanced
topic and i will consider partially
observable probabilistic systems